Hi, I'm Rouli from Free Code Camp. Today we are going to talk about: what is a
network? So, before we answer that
question let's take the example of two
people who are trying to communicate
with each other. So what happens here?
When one person talks he's creating
vibrations in the air which is the
medium and these vibrations reach the
other party and that's how two people
communicate. So one person talks and the vibrations travel through the medium and
reach the other person who is listening.
Now, in case of two computers how do they
talk? They don't have mouths yet or they can't create vibrations in there in the air, so
how do they talk? So, here what we have to do is we need to create some sort of
connection between these two computers. So, a connection between two or more
computers, or more devices, to communicate between them is called a network.